um i want to remind you that as donald
trump has been imploding
and humiliating himself as more and more
states flip to joe biden
donald trump has also continued to fail
fail
fail on coronavirus and the pandemic has
gotten completely out of control
uh donald trump promised 100 million
vaccine doses by the end of october
that's a week ago didn't happen and
unfortunately it pains me to say it dr
fauci's estimate of a hundred thousand
cases a day
is going to end up being way too
conservative yesterday we had
another new record 118
000 cases in a single day with more than
1100 deaths
as we look at the chart of new cases you
see a horrifying trajectory of cases
going higher and higher and higher the
worst
we've seen in the united states and when
you look at deaths
although there's a delay there the
average death numbers have been
increasing for the last three weeks
we are regularly seeing 1100 and 1200
deaths a day again and they are expected
to go much
higher soon we are now approaching in
total in the united states 10 million
cases of coronavirus
we have passed 241 thousand official
deaths and remember
the estimated numbers under represent
the real coronavirus death toll by as
much as 60 70 or 80
even 80 000 additional deaths and donald
trump has failed and leaving
is an emergency his le we need i was
going to say we need new leadership on
the virus
we need leadership on the virus not a
guy threatening to fire fouchy
but a guy who says dr fauci we need you
to address the nation
dr fauci join me in a white house oval
office address
let's start to get this under control
donald trump could have
coasted to reelection had he taken this
seriously he didn't
and he still almost won which we will be
discussing
more next week but contrary to what
donald trump
is has been saying coronavirus doesn't
disappear on november 4th donald trump
really seemed to believe it was a
political ploy just to hurt him
and that november 4th you would never
again hear about the virus
we've not been hearing about it as much
because we're still trying to count all
the ballots
there is a pandemic raging we need adult
leadership
immediately let's hope let's hope
that we get that soon because the next
two months are going to be
brutal and hopefully if we have a lame
duck trump
we will start to get leadership
elsewhere we have a great bonus show for
you today
remember the coupon code brand new
coupon code
fresh start fresh start all one word
use it to save seventy percent
at joinpacman.com we will see you today
on the bonus show